[Music]
well I'm gonna do a quick view on pine
see tree also so after this you had two
explanations it should be really click
it should really click about this
presentation you can download the slides
on get up
decide the presentation is based on a
blog post which you can read on my
website it's more elaborate than what
we're doing today and it's all based on
the on the paper or face book itself
about profit so profit is a is a time
series prediction tool as Facebook
developed I have some assumptions that
you have a little bit prior knowledge
about Bayesian inference it is not
needed but yeah you will understand it a
little bit bit little bit better if you
do and you are a little bit familiar
with pine see tree yeah so this is a
slide from the paper and these are
events Facebook has on a daily basis in
their in their work they have humanly
generated data and that's typical yeah
typical family of data which has got
things like seasonality you've got
weekly cycles you've got a yearly cycle
you've got trends things change over
time
you've got dips at the end of the year
something like all the days and I also
got outliers stuff that you don't want
to model and this is quite yeah
there are quite a lot of aspects in this
data and handling this data yeah to be
able to do so you need to be quite a
time-series expert you you have the
signal you need to explain so you have
an autoregressive part you have a moving
average part but those two those two
algorithms they require your stationary
data so you can't you cannot have a
trend so you need to integrate the data
dimension they have the current time
step you subtract the time step before
that and if it's still as a trend you do
that again and you need to reverse that
when you make a prediction so that's
also a little bit more complicated then
you have a lot of seasonality and
humanly generated data and there's also
the
holiday effects the the extra generous
part you need to model so yeah there's
there are a lot of things you need to
consider so Facebook says yeah we want
to do this on more automatic way and
yeah more robust for for people who just
started with time series so they came
with prophet prophet uses generalized
additive models which is just a fancy
way of saying we yeah take different
parts and add it on in one in one
formula yeah just add different parts
together and that's our final
predictions so they say we have a trend
in the data which we want to explain
we have seasonality we have a lot of
seasonality which we want to explain and
we want to do something with those
holiday effects and of course we also
have an error term for things we cannot
explain if you add those things together
we have our signal at least that's what
we hope to have and they do that on a
Bayesian way and they do that with stung
which is another tool yeah just like
pine Kshatriya
a Bayesian modeling tool so to be yeah
to be formal here here is the official
definition of Bayesian modeling so you
have Bayes rule and in it you see two
parameters you have a theta which stands
for all the possible parameters in your
model AF capital D which is the data you
have observed from the world and we are
interested in a posterior distribution
which is given the data we've seen
what's the probability of our parameters
of the model we want to have yeah highly
probable parameters for our model right
so what we're saying we have some prior
probability we have some prior knowledge
that we put into model we think are our
parameters are likely to be this and we
have the likelihood function that for
all the parameters we can compute our
likely it is given it predefined
distribution but if you multiply those
two together you don't end up with a
probability distribution that's why you
need to
divided by the marginal likelihood so it
sounds up to one well it turns out this
marginal likelihood is a that's an
estimation or an integral over all your
parameters all the possible parameters
so this is really expensive and yeah not
really possible most of the time so
that's why we use it to like pine c3 and
pliancy tree uses a trick called MCMC if
Markov chain Monte Carlo which samples
from the posterior and it's a nice trick
and therefore we don't need to normalize
you can leave it at that for today so
yeah I'm gonna talk a bit about Bayesian
in a nutshell the Facebook uses data
from American football players I don't
watch any American football
so yeah let's say I want to learn
something about American football and I
want to learn something about the
lengths of the players and say that the
standard deviation is known so I know
already know one parameter the standard
deviation is 5 but I don't know anything
about the length now I think American
football players are really long so ever
prior I believe that they are that this
distribution is centered around 1 meter
and 90 centimeters so that's my prior
then I observe two two lengths of two
American football players one guy is 165
the other is 170 okay I've observed
those two data points from the world and
given a a likelihood function let's say
I think it's normally distributed I
think I can Reaper ammeter eyes to
normal distributions and compute the
likelihood of those yeah seeing this
data and then I can multiply those two
together and in the last line here we
normalize it by dividing by the psalm
and then we end up with something like
the posterior and in the right you see
the posterior and you also see the
original prior and the likelihood
closets next to it and you see that the
posterior is something it's in between
so the end result of the posterior is a
combination of our
I believe and the data talking and the
more data we have the more the
likelihood to speak and less the prior
but you can see you can already make
inferences with only two data points so
that's Bayesian in a nutshell and there
is also pine sheet we in a nutshell
nutshell works with context context
managers or with contacts I can start a
pine tree tree context and in that I can
define priors so the first line is prior
a normal distribution with a mean of 190
and standard deviation of five and then
I define a likelihood function which I
assume is also a normal distribution and
I think the mean of this likelihood is
my is my prior but then I will check
with the observed data and I love to
apply my prior with the likelihood and
then I can say if I'm C tree the magic
inference button we heard it in previous
talk sample samples for me from the
posterior and if we plot these samples
we see the same kind of result as we saw
with really computing the the posterior
distribution only as you can see we plot
the histogram is it are really the
samples from posterior so we don't know
the real probabilities but we yeah
because we have samples we can
approximate to build probabilities so
that's really cool so why bother well
you can embed prior believe your model
so you can really really I think this is
very really valuable and if you don't
want to you can just have uninformed
prior say ok I'm likelihood I let you
decide you can regularize with sensible
priors because if you give a very low
prior probability to certain values then
the likelihood can be high there but
yeah a very small number versus a higher
number is still a small number so the
Asteria likelihood posterior probability
will still be low and uncertainty which
is very valuable uncertainty in single
predictions you get you get posterior
distributions for every prediction you
make and
I think this is really important if you
make business decisions and just just
point estimate values yeah I don't know
so let's start with pines no let's start
with profit so in the paper they do they
take some data from pits and many it's
the guy looking at you I had to google
it he is an American football player and
these are these are his Wikipedia views
yeah the first thing what we're gonna do
is min max this data I'm in log scale it
between 0 and 1 because that makes it
very much easier to think about our
prior yeah our prior values because we
know today the data is between 0 & 1 we
and we kind of prior beliefs of what
kind of parameters our model shows have
and then what we're now gonna try to fit
is a linear trend with change points so
we're gonna have a hyper parameter and
we say the world let's say it when you
have 25 change points in this data and
we're gonna make a grid this is
something you define yourself so this is
really a hyper parameter you should
churn tune and what we're saying at this
at exchange points linear trend may
change and how much it must change is
something the data can speak or we can
regularize it with having a sparse prior
saying the change points cannot change
the mods too much so yeah we have a base
growth we say we have some K and if we
do K times T we just have a linear
function a linear trend right what we
want this base grow to be able to change
at every change point so we have a
vector of called Delta with change
points adjustments so we have s change
points that's the number of change
points we've got and we have we've got
this vector and then we say for every
time step T we look at okay every
surpassed a change point if you have
surpassed to change point we modify the
original K with a delta from the vector
so
so over time the the growth rate changes
right so at every at every change point
we suppose we change with the Delta from
the vector and if you look closely to
this summation this is actually a dot
product so we can vectorize this which
will which is needed to be it makes it
easy to work with pine tree tree which
is something yeah which is just
computation library sort of like tensor
flow you need to make linear linear
algebra formulations so we can make a
function a of T where for every every
time T if the time is larger than the
change point we say this is one we have
surpassed this change point if it if we
didn't suppose this change point this is
zero so we have a sort of boolean array
every suppose this change point or not
and then we can just make a dot product
with the original Delta vector the
change points and we can vectorize this
even further we can do this for all T's
in the data and then we get a yeah then
we get a matrix which we can so we can
use this algorithm Y Allah with one
operation yeah
and that leaves us with this so we have
the original changed from the original
growth k plus this matrix a times Delta
times T here we change the growth over a
growth rate over time but if we only
have this left one this left part of the
equation the this part then we will will
not have a continuous function so we
need to offset it with the change points
times as well how does this look we can
make this an umpire with some
broadcasting and then you will have this
plot below you see the growth rate
offset so this is the offset part of the
formula in the middle you see the growth
rate adjustment
so here you see that the growth rate
changes over time and we we have a
increasing trend and if you combine
those two plots we will get the
continuous function above so this is a
way in which we can make a growth rate
plot and you should note I've chosen
some random change points here so this
is not a grid but in the in the
algorithm we just have a grid of change
points but you can also change it it's
up to you and also I've used only
positive Delta's here so that's why it's
increasing but it can go both ways of
course yeah so this part of the model we
can we can create in pine situated to
the left you see a sort of a formal
definition over priors
so kay it comes from a normal
distribution parameterised with 0 and 5
Delta comes from a Laplace I will get to
how that looks
later so given our priors we can define
the trend function which is we've we've
derived just earlier and this trend
function we can put into a likely
function y given given the trend
function and given an error term Delta
and we assume it's it's it is from a
normal distribution where the mean is
equal to the trend function all right
and then we can start sampling so what
you see on the left you see also on the
right in pines the tree so we have those
in those contexts we have the priors and
then we define the trend function and
then we put it in the likelihood
function yeah that's equal and what
we'll get is this so yeah you see a top
you see a linear trend with a different
prior so to the right you see the Criers
I've chosen this is prior Laplace prior
with the scale of 0.05 and this is with
the scale of 0.5 so the first prior is
very very sparse we have a high
probability of yet the change points we
sample or the change adjustments being
equal to zero
and in the prior below you see the
change points adjustments can be quite
high and you also see this back in the
plot so the first one is much more
regularized and second one yeah it's
really free to to to to follow the data
I would say the first one with the
regular wise one is better because in
the in the bottom one we are where we
are actually yeah explaining recurring
patterns with a linear change point
trend which should not be done we should
use seasonality for that so yeah so only
only model modeling the trend isn't
really forecasting because we don't know
how to trend will change over time in
the future so we want to model stuff we
really can yeah can be a little bit more
certain about and the trend to trend is
really I think the hardest thing to do
to forecast and the noise of course so
we need some seasonality profit defines
seasonality via a series free a series
are a summation of sines and cosines
cosine functions yeah rescaled and with
with I think you all know you're about
create transforms we can model any
function with the summation of of sines
and cosines so it's really powerful if
you make the order high enough you can
yeah you can you can model any function
but in this in this formula there are
two things that are hyper parameters
which is P and the N and it's the order
of the NSE order of 3i series P is the
period of the VI series and a and a and
B are learnable parameters something we
need to infer from the data in our model
so here we have an visual visualization
of that this is P and this changes the
yeah the period of our signal right so
now we have one sine function
so we don't plot the cosine but this
also David cosine is just offset in one
face so you have you have boat so and
then you can also change the order of
the free a series and then you get just
multiple signs on top of each other and
you can you can scale each each order so
the scale part is not in this
visualization but yeah that's something
that can be done and these are the the
hyper parameters that are default in
profit so for the yearly seasonality
profit as default of an order of ten and
a period of 365 days which is logical so
the weekly the period is seven and the
order is a bit lower is three but you
can also if you think there's a lot of
things changing and your your weekly
data you can increase the order of
course but yeah your you add more
variance well well what can we do we can
actually extract those learnable
parameters a and B with which we scale
the free a series and just come up with
a factor where we put in the hyper
parameters so type a parameter seven for
weekly data and order of trees and then
we just define this function define this
matrix X of T and we extract the
learnable parameters and call them
better and then we just have a dot
product seems like linear regression
right yeah and we can also code this up
so here you have the same here you have
a function in Python where you just you
put in time you put in the periods you
put in the order and you'll get back
this numpy array with the X's and then
you can come up with any better and not
apply it do the dot product and you will
end up with this plot you see to the
right so that's the seasonality now for
the model we we made a helper function
where we take in the model and we taken
an argument which says I want yearly or
weekly data and we take and the prior we
want to set the prior where we take
where we
yeah where we define ours or scale
parameters a and B for and then we
define these this matrix X and we define
the prior and we return this yeah and
yeah so the complete model without
holidays effects I'm not gonna go to the
holiday of days effects today because I
think those are really easy to implement
it's just a linear regression with dummy
variables so the complete model is the
trend the the linear trend with change
points G of T and seasonality for the
weeklies
for the weekly PT the weekly seasonality
and the yearly seasonality plus some
noise term epsilon so yeah we have G
from the original model we made a few
slides ago we have a prior on beta which
is pretty uninformative with a standard
deviation of 10 it can be anything we
say and then given those free a series
matrix multiplied with that and we end
up with a with this with the seasonality
signal we can and then we can define the
likelihood we assume the likely to be
normally distributed with a mean of the
linear trend plus the seasonality and
then the standard deviation is some
error term Sigma and you see that left
is the sames right right and then we
take a coffee yeah this takes half an
hour if we would do it live and what you
end up it is posterior samples here are
plotted the histograms or the mysterious
samples samples from the posterior for
every parameter in the model you can see
those for instance at the Delta you see
some some this one is very very tidy
which means we are really certain about
the value of this of this parameter
for some we have a more wide
distribution which yeah there is more
variance so this uncertainty is very
powerful what we can actually do is we
implant we implement this model in new
by and compute quantiles for for our
distribution samples so we do that and
we plot the different aspects of our of
our linear over profit model so we have
the trend part that's that's what you
see here we have the yearly seasonality
what you see here and you have the the
weekly seasonality what you see here
yeah you really yeah you call it
subtracted out the different parts and
can really look at them separately and
think it is logical this is what I
expect so it's really explainable I also
see the the the quantiles of your sample
points so these are credible intervals
95% credible info she's here and it
seems like what most places we are quite
certain I think this is because we have
a lot of data points but you would see
if there are less data points in a
certain time period those credible
intervals will be more wide and yeah you
are more uncertain yeah well if you look
at this the the weekly seasonality and
the yearly seasonality is of course
really handy with forecasting you can
just look at the time in a year and you
have those values for the trend it's
it's harder if you look here at the
trend we stopped at eighty percent of
the data eighty percent of the data
points and then we extrapolated linearly
to the end of the data because you can
change this this is a hyper parameter
but I would say you don't want to follow
the trend that you see in one day
because one day can spike and it's
really not reasonable to assume that
this day will spike for the next three
months so you take yeah you look at a
more longer period what your trend is
probably gonna be and you extrapolate
that so that's what's done here but then
for every future change point
we don't want this trend to just
continue because yeah how certain are we
about this so that what profit does it
isn't really Beijing it's just sort of
uncertainty trick and I don't know if
it's if it's if you can see it as I have
this much chance that it will happen but
what they assume is okay I've seen for
instance at every time step T it was a
probability of I've seen 5% change
points in my history then I I'm gonna
assume that for every future time
pointer will also be 5% change points so
at every new time step there will be a
probability of being a change point that
at this point a linear trend can change
and then also the the rate of change
we're gonna assume to be the same as the
mean from the rate of change we've seen
in the past so in words is saying okay I
expect my future to see the seat the
same rate of change as I've seen in the
past and yeah there there is not
mathematical proof of this but this is
more of a yeah over yeah it seems
reasonable right so with this you get
some sort of uncertainty in your trend
prediction so if you would plot only for
the trend and so we started we start
predicting at the time you see there's
credible intervals what we've done we've
sampled we we sample this thousand times
what you you don't sample with Bayesian
but you just apply this formula so you
make a prediction and you look where it
comes and then you do it again and you
do it again and if you do this 1,000
times and then you can make some sort of
credible intervals and you see you have
quite some uncertainty here and that's
also true because in the past you've
seen quite a lot trend change and if you
want this uncertainty to become less you
need to take a more restrictive prior
more sparse prior yeah
so last things I want to say about this
is is that it's really quite easy to use
those additive models to add new parts
new stuff so princess holidays are just
a dummy variable at a certain time step
times a weight you need to learn you can
also add temperature maybe so add
another time series you want to add yeah
just let your imagination go and yeah
you will see something the components
are really understandable and
explainable to business certainly with
those with this uncertainty we've got
and the default priors of profits are
pretty robust a use it to do time series
forecasting without a man-in-the-middle
so they do it automatically and then
maybe do some data scientists who check
on later if it was okay but yeah they
give pretty reasonable forecasting just
out of the box by saying fit predict so
yeah thank you for your time and are the
questions
[Applause]